the doom took Valyria in minutes but the
rest of air sauce wasn't so lucky how to
be swarmed the Dothraki and there were
no dragons to push them back
the Dothraki tide slammed first into the
SAR nori who called themselves the tall
men and whose ancient kingdom dominated
the grasslands of esos the tall man at
first scorned the horselords as
uncivilized barbarians which they were
but calm endo had United all of them
into one khalasar with one aim to
trample the world beneath their hooves
and take other peoples as their herd one
by one the cities of the tall men were
overwhelmed still they wouldn't unite
against the Dothraki many didn't believe
the tales of the rare survivors no army
could move so fast or strike so quickly
they didn't know that the Dothraki live
in the saddle and have such command over
their horses that they seem to have four
legs not to wear most archers fire from
cooked
the Dothraki far from horseback charging
or retreating it makes no matter they
are just as deadly
but the Dothraki prefer close combat
howling for blood as they ride down
their enemies with their rocks and there
were so many of them when Carl mangos
son Carl Morel laid waste to the
waterfalls city of Sofia renaming it the
place of wailing children the tall men
finally realised their peril led by a
High King they assembled a great army to
brake the cars once and for all and met
the Dothraki on what would ever after'
be known as the field of crows the four
cars commanded almost 80 thousand
horsemen between them the tall men had a
hundred thousand foot soldiers ten
thousand armored riders ten thousand
light horsemen
and 6000 scythe chariots as battle was
joined the earth-shattering advance of
the tall man's chariot smashed through
the center of the Dothraki horde the
spinning blades on their wheels slicing
through the legs of the Dothraki horses
when one car went down before them cut
to pieces and trampled his khalasar
broken fled the chariots thundered after
the fleeing horsemen and the high king
and his armored riders plunged in after
them followed by their foot soldiers
waving their spears and screaming in
victory but it was a trap the Dothraki
were not fleeing as the tall men
realized when the horselords suddenly
turned their horses and unleashed a
storm of arrows two more khalasar swept
down on the toll men's flanks
but another attack them from the rear
cutting off their retreat completely
encircled the high king and his mighty
hosts were destroyed the tall man had
stood for thousands of years now the
crows feasted on their corpses has
thought a frankly squabbled over death
the common wisdom is that the Dothraki
tide finally broke upon the spears of
the unsullied at Kuo [ __ ] saving a
sauce from the horselords in truth the
days when the Dothraki could threaten
the entire world had already passed the
great khalasar forged by carl mango had
splintered into a dozen hordes after the
death of the last great calm and the
riders had resumed their petty feuds the
grasslands of air-source are now called
the Dothraki sea but no more nations
drown in it still the Dothraki
priestesses the - colleen prophesied
that one day the Dothraki will gather
advice doth rack their holy capital and
unite once more under the greatest car
of them all the stallion who mounts the
world he will lead their people to the
ends of the earth and grind all nations
to dust beneath them pi nu a Khaleesi
who the priestesses said would give
birth to this stallion
she didn't no doubt the gospel even made
the same prophecy before and will again
world conquest is an alluring dream but
few who dream it ever wake to its
reality
yet could the dothraki united behind one
great leader conquer the world when I
first came to Essos I laughed at the
idea but now most armies rather sell
swords paid to fight who often refused
to die or peasants called up from the
fields and hovels how long would those
armies stand against the charge of a
hundred thousand screamers howling for
blood how well would boiled leather
Jerkins and mailed shirts protect them
but the arrows fall like rain